hey so in this video i'm going to show
you our current problems or challenges
and in the past you could see us
struggling a lot with all these thorns
silvas spiky bushes however you want to
call this
plant
it's been quite aggressive scratches
everywhere and it's just growing all
around us but this problem now actually
turns out to be kind of nice let me show
you
they're still super annoying and way too
spiky
but
now in summertime you actually have a
lot of blackberries growing here
[Music]
uh the lesson here might just be that
every
downside or every challenge also brings
an upside
so we bought this big piece of land and
our prototyping a more sustainable way
of living not sure how it's going to go
but let's see and we document this whole
process and every eighth video we show
you guys our current problems or
challenges and this is video update 28
so today i'm going to show you our
challenges and we're also going to have
some q a all right so let's start off
with the previous challenges and one big
one was the highway sounds they're still
there
uh still not sure what to do we're still
observing so not really an update yet
second one is a weather station we
wanted to make this station that
measures
the climate around here so the
temperature the amount of sun the
humidity the amount of rain that falls
just to understand a little bit better
where we are at and perhaps in different
areas in the land so
there's a special discord where people
working on this and jerry actually sent
us a box
containing some of these sensors
connected to raspberry pi so that one is
now analyzing the data as a first
prototype and hopefully it evolved so
that one is moving forward
next challenge is yearly time lapses we
really want to make some time lapses
that don't last for 20 minutes but
really like a whole year
um because we're going to have a lot of
long-term development here so it would
be cool if you can actually see the
trees growing and the ruins being
renovated
that still needs to be developed i
didn't make much progress there
if you want to help out make sure to
visit
support.projectcamp.com where you can
see how you can help out with that one
and the next big step was also that we
wanted to get water
and in the previous video i've shown you
that we wanted to ask the neighbors if
we could use the well
so i'm now sitting on the top of the lid
from the well uh so this is just a lid
here's a hook so you can lift it up good
news we could actually use the well we
open it up looks super impressive
we went inside to chilly
all good so now we're getting into
getting all the parts components and
actually
installing it which should be
soon besides this we have a few
additional updates one is that we have
project cam pages
if you support on patreon you can get
one of these to support the project
which would be really great and another
small update which is not really a
problem not a problem at all actually is
that we posted a video on
when we cleaned this kitchen and that
video got a lot of use over a hundred
thousand which is more than any of all
the other videos we made
so that has been really great and it
actually boosted the whole channel so
more and more people discovering
project cam because the youtube
algorithm likes that another update is
we now actually have internet for a
while already on the base camp
we figured it out by using different
phone carriers and different kind of
devices and then depending where you are
on the land on the high point or the low
points you have internet so we found for
basecamp what is a good setup is to have
vodafone 4g with a dongle
so you pay one euro per day actually to
have unlimited internet so 30 euro month
it's kind of good
it's been really nice but one downside
of that is that
we put the dongle inside of the
container however the container is a
metal box and the moment you close it
the internet is basically gone
so we need to have a 4g router which we
can put on top of the container so i'm
now actually looking into this topic
i saw this router seems nice also
because you can connect multiple devices
and it has outdoor casing
but i'm not sure i don't know too much
about these things no experience with it
so if you guys have any tips or
suggestions on this or want to figure
out the best outdoor router
let me know would be very useful
[Music]
all right so let's get on with our
current challenges and i would say we
have a lot of small ones but three kind
of big ones that are currently on our
mind first one is video making so here
we have a question from stefan g that
sort of introduces it a bit could you
please talk a little bit about how the
filming fits into your day your videos
are looking very good if you consider
that you don't have a man see i would
say the video making is kind of a
challenge actually
on the one hand just to really produce a
video each week but i think also more uh
yeah really producing it from the
beginning till the end so you really
start to think of something you want to
do then you're going to sketch it out
then you're going to either make it or
clean it then you film it all then you
edit it
so at the end when you're making the
edit of the video you're completely done
with it because you've been into the
process for so long in all these little
steps
so i think it's going to be hard to keep
this up in the long term especially with
more projects coming up more people
coming
so i think yeah we really need to find a
way to make sure we can keep this up
because i do like it a lot having weekly
updates to share with you guys so if
you're a video maker want to help let us
know
but it is also challenging actually
because uh there are a lot of things
going on so you kind of need to really
be here
for a long period of time because we
also don't want a different kind of
video style every week it somewhat needs
to be consistent
so i'm not sure how we're going to do
that but it's a it's a bit of a
challenge as my energy level or videos
making is slowly going down challenge 2
based on a question from jacqueline
how is your workshop turning out and is
there lots of bugs where you live and is
it a problem for you
okay this sounds silly but it's actually
quite a thing having all these flies
especially when you're doing focused
work you have a fly like what's in your
eye or your leg it's like ah
especially when it gets hot it's already
hard to focus with the heat but then
also with the flies around and it also
looks like they like the same places as
humans so if you take shady place like a
container to do some focusing work they
also are here
so yeah it's it's challenging i think in
general i still have to get used a bit
through the heat he does better with it
but i'm now trying to get up earlier
when it's still cool and in the middle
of the day take a siesta or work in the
water and then continue my focus work
more in the afternoon when it cools down
a bit again
challenge number three
it's actually kind of an exciting one
but it's a big one it's about planning
ahead and seeing how we're going to do
it
because up until now the focus has been
very much setting up base camp so making
sure we have some basic infrastructure
here water electricity toilet
and we're getting there to the states
that we set it up
so now we're thinking about okay what to
do next because we identified the land
we've seen what to do
and we cleaned up some ruins that we
know need work
so on the one hand uh we just have a lot
of work to do like actual uh workforce
and but also quite some organization and
if you have more people how you manage
that and also really just the resources
like how do we gonna pull it off because
up until now we've only been really
working on this small patch
but we have like 10 hectares out there
which we need to take care of so
everything quickly skills up also in the
amount of resources and we didn't really
think it through too much i'm pretty
sure we'll find a way
but it's a challenge and yeah if you
want to help out make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com to see how you
can do it either financially or with
your workforce and you got a badge
all right so now we're going to the q
and a part where we're going to answer
some questions originally i wanted to do
this with rita because she's been here
with me basically the whole time so she
also knows the project inside out
however she is currently in the south of
portugal so she's not here and you might
have seen in the videos that
occasionally people help out as well so
our moms were here and mattia from italy
leo from porto
are you and the italian girl a couple
uh no me and mattia are not a couple so
yeah we had some people coming by every
now and then
but now we actually also have one person
here that is actually going to help for
a longer period of time
he's named ian
[Music]
[Applause]
so here we have ian and he's building a
compost toilet
yeah he's the first person helping out
for longer periods of time kind of
exciting to see how it's going to go
but it's getting a bit noisy here so
i'll find a place to do the q a
i actually kind of like doing this feels
useful to answer your questions and kind
of easy for me
so the first question from yoga are you
going to answer them
yes that's the plan alright so second
question we saw you planting trees and
shrubs in the early video how they're
doing they're doing quite well actually
especially over there you can see our
lemongrass
and vavena has been really growing
massively
i always drink teas from this
actually everything here grows super
fast in portugal because
at least in this part because you have a
lot of
sun and a lot of water and rain so yeah
good ingredients
how is your garden going is it still
going strong after the hill storm
for that we have to look at this avocado
and that quite some uh
worn out
leaves from the hill storm
uh it's coming back now but they
actually did take quite a hit so i would
say our trees are not growing that
fast i think it's a combination of
replanting them too late and the big
hill storm which really just shredded
all of them
peach tree over there is doing very well
actually but all the other ones here you
can see a bit around me are just some
sticks
maybe next year they'll come or maybe we
replant a few of those
but let's actually go to a more quiet
place where also some shade
[Applause]
will farming be the largest strongest
component of your envisioned sustainable
lifestyle to be honest i'm not sure yet
the land is definitely good for farming
a lot of people around us would
recommend it
however we sustainability also has
something that is not isolated it sort
of depends on your land but also your
region so if a lot of people around us
already growing vegetables in the right
way
it makes less sense for us to also do
that and actually compete with them so
for instance in the last video you saw
sara nunu growing their own vegetables
so in a way it's perfect for us if we
can work with them to get their
vegetables
because also then they become really
expert in that area and they can really
dive deep into it and if it's us then we
have to do like 20 different things
so instead of growing vegetables maybe
it's better if we spent our time on
something else but not sure yet
why aren't you growing your own
vegetables and fruits
so no vegetables for the previous region
i just mentioned but fruits i could
actually see being integrated easier
because uh they're just less hassle to
maintain once you plant them they grow
especially in this climate around here
so yeah fruits is probably a realistic
part of our land
how did you imagine life and work on
your land would look like from the
beginning as you went through the
workshop container there were a lot of
all kind of machines to work with metal
screws you will put those things to use
in the future i'm sure but what about
forest and land management tools wood
chipper brush cutter chainsaws
yeah good question that is definitely
lacking those tools
but the tools we got in our workspace
basically came because we already had a
workspace back into the netherlands so
it's a bit of a mixture of it's a
workspace but also just moving our own
stuff
so yeah we decided to not buy any of
this in the netherlands but just see
here what we actually need and then just
slowly expand our workspace with more
landscaping tools
but yeah i would highly recommend if
you're going to start a project like
this and you don't have a metal late yet
don't get it get yourself a chainsaw or
something
when will you start making houses out of
plastic bricks
yeah
as soon as possible the kitchen building
looks really makeshift no straight walls
big gaps that are filled with concrete
missing bricks why renovating instead of
rebuilding i would say in general
because we prefer to reuse the things
you could even take the whole building
apart and recycle the bricks but
realistically it always demolishes it a
bit more
it breaks the parts so ideally we use
things in their original condition but i
have no clue if it would make sense with
the kitchen actually to do this we're
still looking into that right now can
you make a playlist that starts at
episode 1 so your journey can be watched
in order yes done that especially for
you how much price and how big is the
land there
we actually made a video about that on
our other channel i would highly
recommend to watch because it has all
the details
and in general we have this two channels
this is more for weekly updates and the
other one is more for the long-term
documentation
what does it mean prototyping a more
sustainable way of living not sure i
guess that's why we call it a prototype
you often say sustainable but what do
you actually mean by that ecologically
sustainable economically sustainable
physically sustainable
all of the above and in which case do
you decide to balance them
yeah very good question
complex as well i don't have the answer
to be honest but i do think that's what
we mean with prototyping so for instance
in today's world we often really focus
on the details of things so for instance
let's say you could design a stove that
is slightly more efficient so everyone
that cooks at home uses less energy
but sometimes it feels we might just
have to rethink how we cook because
instead of everyone individually cooking
maybe it makes more sense if you share
your meals so you don't need all this
individual stove you don't have all
these individual waste streams you don't
have all the individual
energy usage
but it's very hard to integrate in the
usual world and i think at project camp
we're starting a bit more from scratch
so we could really rethink how we live
and how we set up our daily routines
because it affects the way you eat the
way you use your infrastructure what you
do in your free time like i feel all
these topics are connected and how to
live sustainable but yeah very hard to
integrate in an existing system so here
it feels like we can prototype and
really tweak all these topics in a more
holistic approach
but yeah not sure how it's going to go
what makes project camp different than
all the other projects out there
yeah probably that we have highway
sounds i didn't hear that before
no but i do think this element of
community you have a lot of people going
as a couple living off grid kind of
looks like we did that until now i guess
but i think this really starts to get
excited when the community kicks in and
it becomes about
sharing resources and
infrastructure which we would start
doing more soon
when will project camp get the band back
together and or accept more volunteers
yeah so we're slowly approaching that as
a base camp is being set up we're still
not sure how to manage this because yeah
it also comes with some organization but
i would say soon what's the maximum
amount of people you're expecting to
have on the land at one time
i think we had no clue when we came here
like even
10 hectares like how many people could
live there what makes sense that you're
that is not chaos all the time but you
still have enough private space
as we're here we're starting to slowly
see it more
uh i still don't have an exact number i
think it could host quite some people
uh maybe like max 50 or something in
order it's for it to still be nice
but yeah we're still going to take a
while as well before we can host that
many people
how do you keep yourself entertained are
you lonely sometimes what is your social
life like
good question
so yeah personally i am pretty good in
entertaining myself on my own i always
see a thousand things i could do rita is
a bit more a social being so she really
likes to have people around so at this
moment it's a bit more hard for her
but i would say as he knows more people
are coming which makes it okay
but in general a lot to do so it's not
very easy to get bored but i do think we
need to figure out these things more
like what are our routines how do we
take off on this project and what do we
do in our free time how are you feeling
is living this way you expect it to be
uh yeah i guess i don't know what my
expectations were it also feels like
this is not really how we're gonna live
it's still very rough and raw now so it
feels very temporary the things we're
currently doing
but overall it's nice to spend more time
in nature the mental strain of what have
i got into during the rain season looked
like it sucked for a bit how are you
doing now apart from the highway saints
how is the spirits yeah i think they go
up and down
especially because we're sort of
analyzing this land and sometimes we
have these issues like the highway
sounds or the rain that you know they
affect us but also everyone that's gonna
go to project camp sort of be affected
by that so they feel quite heavy which
brings the spirits down
but then other days uh we have good
things
so i would say overall it's kind of
intense
but
yeah i guess that's part of it
do you want to make project come
something like a modern farm or rather
something like a rural lab or workshop
similar to fresh plastic or something
entirely different
do you have a concrete vision or are
planning things as you go yeah so we
would love to have more of these topics
on this land but realistically
integrating something like fresh plastic
here is quite challenging because you
first need to run your own basic life
having enough resources for yourself but
then also to run for instance
three-phase machines to do
experimentations and stuff and hosting
the people and making sure they have a
meal
it still feels like far away so in the
future it would be cool but it might
still take some time
is there anything that you learned
working on fresh plastic that is really
helping you with this project
yeah i think a lot actually during
pressure plastic version 4 where we
brought a lot of people together
to work on a shared mission
and that was really great i mean again
we made this video about it
so i would highly recommend to watch if
you're interested
but we learned a lot of uh community
lessons from that and i think it also
made it less scary to do this project
because you kind of feel like with the
right people you you get anything done
is the forks real so close yes very real
they actually come almost every evening
when we're in the town center they're
just walking by having a look playing
with some things that we left there it's
super nice what's your plan dealing with
all the invasive mimosas on your land
what about ecolyptus you plan on keeping
them any plans of repopulating the land
with endemic trees
yeah very much on our reader to make
sure we do something with it we haven't
really are ourselves three experts we're
still looking for someone that is
but overall also plan for this winter to
make more of a landscape plan on what to
do with this whole terrain
so yeah probably a lot of those have to
go
alright so that was this video it's
actually super nice that you guys watch
these videos and like them and i relate
to the topic
because it's motivational for us but
also still just a lot to figure out and
we still need a lot of people helping
and supporting the project so we really
benefit having this community around it
and as you noticed still a lot of stuff
is unclear
we don't have the answers to everything
that's why we're doing it to try to
figure out and it started as a black
hole where we dove into feels a bit like
a grey hole now so we're making progress
so yeah thanks for watching see you in
the next video [ __ ] flies do
you like them oh yeah i love them so
much can you hear how much i love them
you sing oh as we're talking gets in my
ear